wenden der städte zu sehen sind hier
beim streetlife festival in chur wird
natürlich legal gesprayt und gemalt aber
das ist die große ausnahme
und davon kann der urvater aller
schweizer spielerinnen sprayer harald
nägeli ein lied singen vor kurzem
entkamen einem weiteren rechtsstreit
wegen sachbeschädigung nur durch eine
symbolische geste
er schenkte der stadt zürich einen
echten nägeli auf leinwand natürlich
nicht auf hauswand hat nägel ist
zauberhafte wesen die er vor 40 jahren
erstmals an zwischen hauswänden tanzen
ließ die hingegen sind nach wie vor
nicht toleriert wie überhaupt alles was
in der schweiz illegal hin gesprengt
wird
auch verteidigung
das boot muss es zahlen
diese länder selber wegputzt
entsprechend markieren im öffentlichen
raum
pfui da gibt's kein pardon groß ist die
empörung
heute wie damals in den 70er jahren als
ein unbekannter in zürich sein unwesen
trieb und nachts hunderte dieser
irritierenden figuren an die wand
sprühte
irgendwelche fertig ich war ein richtig
für zürich ein schock in new york
bereits alltäglich sprayer besetzten mit
ihren tags die stadt diese anarchische
subkultur ein horrorszenario für die
gutbürgerliche schweizer gesellschaft in
zürich gingen über 100 anzeigen wegen
sachbeschädigung ein nicht zu bremsen
der weiterhin unerkannte urheber auch
das schweizer fernsehen musste zuerst
lernen das phänomen in worte zu fassen
eine stadt sucht einen sprayer nachts
ist er unterwegs man kennt ihn nicht man
kennt nur seine spuren an wänden und
fassaden der nacht sprayer nun gesucht
mit internationalem haftbefehl
schließlich stellte er sich der polizei
sein name harald nagel ehemaliger
kunststudent künstler bejubelten den
sprayer von zürich an seiner seite
joseph beuys
[Musik]
mehrere monate verbrachte harald nagel
die hinter gittern
seine werke wurden fast ausnahmslos dem
sauberkeits bedürfnis geopfert erst
später wandelte sich das kunst
bewusstsein in der 90er jahren waren
nagels werke im kunsthaus zürich
willkommen figuren die an abgelegenen
orten nicht weggeputzt worden waren
galten plötzlich als erhaltenswert als
wertvolle zeitdokumente
sieben dieser werke hat die stadt zürich
in ihre sammlung aufgenommen und
verpflichtet sich damit welch schöne
pointe die einst verhassten werke zu
pflegen
sie ist so gratis zu bildern eines
künstlers von rang und namen gekommen
nachahmer haben aber keine chance kaum
hin gesprengt sind die markierungen
schon wieder weg ihr möglicher wert
interessiert nicht
priska rast die graffiti beauftragte der
stadt zürich kennt sich mit den bildern
aus und begründet die null toleranz hat
sich der klar bessere das städtische
baute waren sie illegal besprüht werden
ganz diskussionslos leidet es wird
diskutiert über den wert oder möglichen
inhalte dass kunst sondern vieles wird
entfernt
harald nagel die aber kann nicht von der
spraydose lassen
der künstler musste letztes jahr wegen
sachbeschädigung vor gericht erscheinen
was er zürich vor fünf jahren bescherte
war immer noch illegal
es lebe die kunst und die
sachbeschädigung so zum teufel
sachbeschädigung oder kunst im
öffentlichen raum
diese frage klärt das gericht nicht denn
es setzte das urteil aus nagl die
einigte sich mit der stadt
außergerichtlich als schadenersatz
überließ er ihr ein bild auf leinwand
wie es sich gehört
und die welt oder zumindest die schweiz
ist wieder in ordnung solange die wände
sauber sind
es soll bloß keiner auf falsche ideen
kommen früheren reporterin kühlt sie
auch voll und das konzert zum
sicherheitsempfinden busse und so
beschränkt sich der spielraum für
graffiti künstler auf einige wenige
flächen welche die stadt für sie bereit
stellt
schön abseits vom geschäftigen zentrum
[Musik]
dort wo es keinen stört